want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best belief life and learn the five
simple ways to break any bad habit
quickly
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with way number
one optimize your environment with james
clear let's say that you wanted to build
a better i'll give you i'll give you an
example breaking a good hat or building
a good habit and breaking a bad one so
one of the laws is to make it obvious
and this largely comes down to like what
we're exposed to each year each day and
minimalism and simplicity plays a big
role in this in the book i call it
environment design that's basically the
strategy so for a long time i realized
that i brushed my teeth twice a day but
i didn't floss consistently and when i
looked at that habit one of the reasons
that i wasn't flossing consistently is
because the floss was hidden in the
drawer in the bathroom so i just
wouldn't see it you know like i wouldn't
open up the drawer and remember
so i bought a little bowl and got some
of the pre-made flossers and put them in
the bowl and place it right next to my
toothbrush so now i brush my teeth put
the toothbrush down pick the flosser up
it's right there just that one little
environment design change is pretty much
all i needed to do
to build the habit of flossing every day
on the other side let's say you know a
lot of people feel like they spend too
much time watching tv or playing video
games or just looking at a screen but if
you walk into pretty much any living
room where do all the couches and chairs
face they all face the television so
it's like what is that room designed to
get you to do it's designed to get you
to watch tv
so there are a variety of
levels to this you could for example
take the remote and take it off of the
coffee table and put it inside a drawer
or you could take the television and put
it inside like a wall unit or a cabinet
so you don't see it
you could also increase the friction of
the task so you could like take the
batteries out of the remote um after
each use and then you know it's an extra
five or ten seconds put it in maybe
that's just enough time if you think do
i really want to watch something or am i
just doing this mindlessly
you could
unplug the tv after each individual use
and then only plug it in if you can say
the name of the show you want to watch
so you can't like mindlessly browse on
netflix
and i mean if you really wanted to be
extreme about it you could take the tv
off the wall
put it in the closet and then only take
it out when you really wanted to watch
something but the point here and this is
kind of the principle of environment
design in general which is
you want to put fewer steps between you
and the good behaviors and more steps
between you and the bad ones and imagine
the cumulative impact of living an
environment that exposes you to the cues
of your positive habits and reduces the
cues of your negative habits it's kind
of like you're just gently being nudged
in the right direction each day and
that's just one of the of the ways that
you can sort of design a system that
leads you into better habits in my
personal life
you know like there's a moment around 5
15 each night my wife gets home from
work and either we change into our
workout clothes and we go to the gym or
we don't change into our workout clothes
and we watch you know reruns the office
and order takeout or whatever
and really the next two hours are kind
of determined by
that decisive moment of whether we
change into our workout clothes or not
if we change it close then like
everything else is going to happen
automatically we're going to drive to
the gym i'll get it under the bar i'll
do it's already pre-decided basically
so
one of the realizations of this and it
comes back to your kind of central
question of what you know what are the
most important habits to build or are
there ones that ripple into other areas
of life
if you can just master maybe
five or ten decisive moments throughout
the day these little kind of two-minute
chunks that determine the next block of
time
you really only have to focus your
attention and energy on that and the the
the rest of it kind of comes easily you
don't have to do that much uh if you can
master the right moments it's kind of
like judo for your personal habits you
know you apply the pressure in the right
place and everything else kind of falls
in line way number two reprogram your
mind with dr joe dispenza a habit is a
redundant set of automatic unconscious
thoughts behaviors and emotions that's
acquired through repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind
so now the person
running through the same routine every
single day is on autopilot and their
body's now dragging them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists is the sweet spot of
the generous present moment that is when
the body and mind are free from those
conditions so along with those emotions
that influence the same thoughts
people start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled
they start getting more afraid more
anxious more depressed and now the body
is literally being depleted
of energy because it's believing that
it's living in an emergency situation
and in emergency you tap all the body's
resources for some threat whether it's
real or imagined
and so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool
but the arousal that's created from
those stress hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems
and the conditions in their life to
reaffirm their conditioning or their
addiction to that emotion
and in a sense they become addicted to
the life they don't even like
and this is why change is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay i'm not
going to say i can't i'm not going to
judge another person i'm not going to
blame i'm not going to complain i'm not
going to make excuses i'm not going to
be a victim i'm not going to talk trash
about anybody i'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours
and the bodies saying you're out of
schedule you normally at eight in the
morning you get in traffic and you're
angry then at 11 o'clock you check your
emails and you're really judgmental and
frustrated the body's saying well you've
been doing this for the last 20 years
you're just going to stop today so now
the body which has been conditioned
emotionally to be the mind wants to
return back to its familiar territory to
the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on
this is a good time to judge that come
on this is a good time to suffer it's
your ex's fault it's it's your it's the
government's fault it's uh
you know it's the weather what the news
whatever it is and if we
accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those pharmacy of
chemicals
and so
that's when the person makes the same
choice
does the same thing
creates the same experience just for
that familiar feeling okay i'll complain
just so i can feel suffering then
they'd rather
be unhappy
and step into the unknown to step into
possibility and the hardest part about
that process
first of all is not making the same
choice as you did day before
and here's the payoff
you got to stay conscious
and not go unconscious and it turns out
that 95 of the time we're unconscious so
if you're going to stay conscious then
there's an element that also requires a
certain amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so
the thoughts that they're thinking
are slipping by their awareness
unnoticed because they're hardwired in
their brain because they've been saying
i can't it's too hard my life will never
change it's someone else's fault those
thoughts have consequences in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious
of those unconscious thoughts becomes
aware of how they speak and how they act
and they notice
how they're feeling they're no longer
the program they're the consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
there are when you when you're
distracted by your environment and you
got your cell phone and your tweeting
and your
instagramming and facebook and whatever
people do you're distracted by that
feeling
but i now know that if you take a person
and you say okay close your eyes
sit in the in the silence of any
external stimulation remove the
environment sit your body down like an
animal body is the animal tell it to
stay i'm gonna feed you
you can check your cell phone you can
shower you can have your coffee but when
i say
and so then here comes the challenge
right so and and then
if you say then you're not going to live
in the familiar future familiar past or
predictable future you're not going to
think about how long you've been
meditating what you got to do you you
labor
for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it
but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say i
think i'm meditating wrong i always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and
check your cell phone or have a cup of
coffee and you become aware that it's on
autopilot and wants to do that and you
say
come on over here
and you return it back to the present
moment
you're executing a will now
that's greater than the program and if
the person
wants to just get angry while they're
sitting there there's an arousal and
they notice the body is amping up and
revving up and they settle it back down
now they're telling the body it's no
longer the mind
that they're the mind now we've
researched this and it's tedious
in the beginning at first because david
is fighting goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner or later the body is trained to a
new mind and when that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from the body as
energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life
and they're
they're working and lowering the volume
that emotion the more they lower the
volume of that emotion the more they're
going to take their attention off that
person and problem and they're going to
take their power back there's going to
be a break
in their attention from that
circumstance and now they build their
own field and now there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because they've overcome their
old personality self so
i think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming
overcoming
overcoming overcoming until we become
somebody else and when that occurs
and the person starts thinking
differently
and they start acting differently
and they start feeling differently
they're a new personality and yeah they
they start seeing those synchronicities
and serendipities now
crossing that river of change
the creative process now gets exciting
because what thoughts do you want to
fire in wire in your brain what kind of
attention and intention
do you want to place so that that
becomes the loudest voice in your head
and if you keep practicing it the
hardware becomes a software program and
it'll say jay you can do anything jay
you live in no time and accomplish
everything jay
you're unlimited you just got to hang
with it on the other side of this is
greatness whatever you want to program
in there you get to program in there
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there way number three use the 5r
technique with j shetty we have five
senses sight smell touch taste and
hearing now all of these have different
triggers so if we think about food you
see good food right or let's say you see
junk food you smell that junk food you
know what that junk food tastes like you
don't hear junk food i don't think
anyway and as soon as that happens
there's a response that goes straight to
your mind now what happens in your mind
and as you can see this is a very
accurate drawing of what your mind
really looks like inside but this area
of your mind it reminds you of your past
experiences you've had so when you see
those fries you smell those fries you
see those fries you touch those fries it
sends a response to your mind your mind
knows what those fries taste like it
remembers the last time you had them and
how good they felt and straightaway goes
yes let's have them and so the mind goes
sure let's go and plan and create and
now we have those now we start to eat
that and that is a recurring habit and
cycle in our life it happens from
everything from food that's bad for us
to toxic relationships through to making
bad career decisions the simple act of
reminding ourselves of a positive
experience with someone or something
allows us to continue that repetition
but now we all know this we all know
that discipline is a core pillar in
success
we all know that being able to resist
the urges of the mind can help us be
more focused
we all don't want to just be carried
away procrastinating and overthinking
all day we also don't want to live in a
place where we just keep feeding our
bodies and minds with stuff that's not
good for it i know that you feel that i
know that's why you're here and so
there's one key thing that makes a
difference now give me a moment while i
draw this for you it's pretty much a
work of art so i need some privacy just
to get this right
[Music]
so now as you can see the god is the
monk mind the intelligence the monk mind
that stands in between the senses and
the mind so now
for most of us our monk mind is asleep
our god is absolutely asleep or has been
lazy for a while and therefore we've
been in this recurring pattern but this
now creates a new conversation so now
every time there's something that you
see that you want or smell or touch or
taste or hear
it first goes to the god
and the god may say well by the way you
just made a commitment last week that
you want to stay off eating sugar you
just made a commitment last week that
you were going to work out three days a
week right i'm going to make sure that
you stick to that so even though your
eyes are saying that bed looks more
comfy than that bench press we are gonna
go back and now it stops you from having
that direct conversation with your mind
which is always looking for that monkey
mind and the easy way out so you've now
added a level of conversation that's
stronger but you're like but jay i mean
you know is that willpower is that
internal strength where does that god
where does that monk mind come from so
the monk mind comes from the following
principle so the way we strengthen the
monk mind and the god inside our minds
so that we don't just give in to the
temptations and the urges of the mind is
through the four r's format so these
four r's have to be done in order and
when they're executed effectively you
will know that your god and your monk
mind is getting stronger the first r is
reason
you need a really powerful reason for
why you're making this new change in
your life if you don't have a deep
profound reason in your life it'll be
really really difficult i'll give you an
example if someone says that they want
to quit drinking alcohol just because
they want to do it it's different from
someone saying i want to quit drinking
alcohol because i want to save my family
i want to keep my family together and
this habit is ruining our interactions
and so i really want to kick this habit
notice the difference in reason right
even if we want to learn something it's
like oh i want to learn to play an
instrument why oh just because i feel
like it or i want to learn to play an
instrument because i want to propose by
playing the piano notice the depth of
reason
reason is the first r that's needed to
strengthen the god and it's almost like
the god building its foundation so the
monk mind is based on creating a strong
sense of reason now what i want you to
do is choose that one thing you're
trying to change in your life right now
and i want you to ask yourself what's
your real reason for wanting to change
it what is your deep reason for wanting
to change it now our reasons can also be
negative or positive
a negative reason can be revenge or
negative reason can be getting our own
back or showing people
right it's kind of like that look at me
now kind of feeling and we know that in
the long term that won't satisfy us
because again we're seeking validation
from someone feeling differently about
us but our reason being for people that
we love a reason being for ourselves a
reason being a really heartfelt
deep internal belief
that if we don't change this
it's not going to be good for us all the
people we love and so the first r is
having a really strong reason so i'm
just going to write that down
so reason
putting a check next to reason
the second r that we need in our life
is research your reason is given more
ammunition and depth through good
research what i mean by that is you may
pick up the phone to a coach you may
speak to someone who's already mastered
that habit you may focus on reading
about books and watching documentaries
and listening to podcasts about that
subject the more you absorb information
the more likely you are to create
transformation remember that the more
you absorb information
the more you're likely to create
transformation because now you have so
much research that is consistently
convincing the god to help convince the
senses every time you want something or
see something or chase something the god
can say but do you remember when we read
that study
do you remember when we watched that
documentary do you remember when you
spoke to that coach and all of a sudden
you have so much more reasoning power
when you research so the second step is
research and the best way are books
podcasts and people right books podcasts
and people are the best forms of
research when you want to create a habit
change in your life make sure that what
you listen to what you read and what you
speak about is about the subject you're
trying to grow in when you immerse
yourself in that way you will see
maximum impact in your life so the
second r is research
[Music]
the third r
is repetition
repetition
if we don't consistently make this a
priority in our life it's just not going
to happen we have to repeat that action
so we have to prioritize around it and
this is something i say often right if
you really want to make something a
priority in your life
it has to be a small step
and a big priority often what we try and
do is we try and change every area of
our life
and then naturally nothing changes but
the better thing to do is choose one
area and make it your top priority so if
you want to start going to the gym make
that the one big thing you're going to
achieve that day and set a time that you
can actually make it don't set it at an
awkward time i know someone who
literally
used to struggle working out so instead
of that what she would do is when she
would roll off the bed she would have
her yoga mat and all of her gym
equipment laid out right near her bed so
she had no excuse right it was the first
thing she saw in the morning and so she
could naturally start exercising
straight away that also is true for not
triggering the senses right repetition
also includes if you're trying to stay
off sugar if you just don't have any
sugar items in your closet or in your
cupboard or in the fridge then there's
no chance that you're going to have it
so you can actually save yourself by
removing it from the trigger of the
senses
so that is repetition
the fourth r is responsibility right you
want to be able to do this with someone
you want to feel like you're growing
with someone that's why having a tribe
or a community or a group of people that
are trying to aim for the same thing
means you're more likely to get there
you know if you're trying to start a new
habit like cycling more if you're
cycling with a group of people now guess
what you're not just relying on your
motivation you're relying on 10 other
people to motivate you as well if you're
going to the gym with a friend
responsibility and accountability
makes you more likely to get to your
destination and there's a fifth hour
actually that i just thought of and it's
called reward you want to make sure that
in any habit change there is some reward
and a reward is making sure you
recognize what amazing growth you're
making that you're taking a moment to
see look how far i've come because our
mind again tricks us and always goes
look how far you have to go it's really
important that you remind yourself of
how far you've come how much you've
grown the difference you've made so the
fifth and final hour is reward way
number four set proper goals with jordan
peterson get your goals straight and
continue to practice every day and if
you're not succeeding then make your
goals slightly smaller you want to you
want to make your goals large enough so
that they challenge you but small enough
so that you have a reasonable
probability of succeeding at them on a
day-to-day basis
and then you have to also understand
that if you fail on a given day like
let's say you're trying to quit smoking
and you quit for two weeks and then you
have a cigarette and you think oh my god
now i've screwed it up i've i'm not
quitting anymore you smoke a whole pack
of cigarettes it's like well
there's a couple of mistakes there and
one is
well just because you had a cigarette
doesn't mean you failed it just means
that you had a cigarette you can start
stopping again the next day
and the fact that you had one cigarette
in the last two weeks is a hell of a lot
better than the two weeks that you had
before that
and so you've got to be
realistically humble you've got to be
ambitious enough in your goals so that
you're pursuing something that you
regard as truly meaningful and
worthwhile
you know and maybe you can judge that to
some degree if you think about someone
you love attempting the same thing and
think about how you would feel if they
managed it and if you would feel good
then that's probably a good
um
what would you say that would be a good
evaluation strategy to use on yourself
so you want your goals to be of
sufficient nobility so that you can live
with yourself properly if you're
pursuing them but you want them to be
small enough so that you have a
reasonable probability of implementing
them and way number five the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
use affirmations with brian tracy create
an affirmation that you repeat over and
over to yourself
this repetition dramatically increases
the speed at which you develop the new
habit for example you can say something
like i get up and get going immediately
at 6 00 am each morning
repeat these words the last thing before
you fall asleep
in most cases you will automatically
wake up minutes before the alarm clock
goes off at 6am and soon you will need
no alarm clock at all now i've got a
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day i want to
know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch a video and just get motivated the
science says you have a 35 chance of
actually following through on your goals
that's not good enough no not for you
believe nation we got to do something
but when you write it down and you
create a specific plan of action for the
next week that number jumps to 91 chance
of you following through and when you
commit to somebody else like leaving a
comment on this video it jumps to 95 you
need to follow through on your goals so
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your specific plan
of action for the next week put it down
in the comments below so i can celebrate
you you need to tie your self-worth to
the effort not the results if you tie
yourself forth to the results to
achieving your goals then you'll only
take on things that you think you have a
high chance of winning at you'll
constantly quit on your big goals and
only go after the small ones
tie yourself forth to trying to the
effort to doing it when it's hard make
yourself proud with the effort that you
put in not just when you win but if you
keep getting up every day and putting an
effort that you are proud of you will
wane on a level that you never thought
was possible so i just came back from
doing my 90-day tour 23 cities and one
of my goals was i wanted to stay healthy
on my tour one of my advices is it's
hard for me to stay healthy when i
travel and that's okay when you're only
going for a day or two or a week at a
time i eat whatever i wanted and then
came back and got back on my healthy
journey but 90 days on the road that's a
lot of time i could do a lot of damage
if i ate like i normally ate and so i
wanted to feel proud of my effort
of being able to eat healthy and so i
think it's good to take on difficult
things how do you become proud of your
effort you do things that are difficult
to you if it's easy and you win you
don't care that's not how you build your
self-esteem but when it's hard and you
do it that's when you start to feel good
about yourself that's when you start to
build your pride that's where you build
your self-confidence and so one of the
first stops that we made along the way
in ohio was at raising canes this is
famous chicken place where they told us
you have to go to raising cane you have
to go there you've got to go you got to
try their fried chicken it's the best in
the world
great
at the end of my event
we went but it wasn't my cheat day yet
eating healthy i had to pick six days a
week it wasn't my cheat day yet and so
we went
and i went in and i smelled the chicken
and nina and danny my camera guy went in
and they bought it and i said nina can i
can i have your chicken can i just i
just want to hold it and i want to smell
it and so
my mouth is warming right now just
thinking about it i took her chicken
instead of staying home and like you
guys go out and eat no i want to come
i don't want to take the easy path i
want the difficult way i want to be
proud of my effort
so i took the chicken that she had and i
brought it up to my nose and i took a
baby
[Music]
it took a big smell in
it was so good my mouth was watering so
much and then they had this special
sauce this dipping sauce that i took and
i brought it up again
smelled it i can smell it right now
and then i give it back to her
not a single bite here you go enjoy your
chicken
i'm proud of my effort i'm patting
myself on the back i'm doing things that
are difficult
in service of my goals in service of my
ambition but i'm proud of where i am
right now what i'm doing right now and
the small wins along the way i'm proud
of my effort
now that may seem a little bit crazy
of how to stick to a diet
but i think teaching yourself that you
can't be around bad food is actually
counterproductive you're teaching
yourself that you're not strong
when people say get rid of the junk food
from your house
i think you're teaching yourself that
you're not strong that you can't be
around it and then as soon as you go on
vacation as soon as you go to an office
party as soon as you get out of your
house you're screwed
because you're teaching yourself you
have no tolerance you have no resistance
that you are weak in this area and so i
want to combat that i want to be proud
of the effort i put in and gain strength
along the way and so when my friends are
on a diet i tell them the same thing a
buddy of mine mark drager
is on a diet right now and he wants to
lose an extra 10 pounds i told him
here's what you do take your favorite
food what's your favorite food and he
said cookies take your favorite food
bring it to the office i want you to be
around it be around the cookies
take a smell
and then put it down
and tell yourself that you are awesome
i'm stronger than you cookies because
you're proud of your effort because
you're trying because you're doing the
difficult things instead of taking the
easy way out and teaching yourself that
you're weak so how can you be proud of
your effort and start making progress
towards your goals i'm going to give you
a three-step process on how to do it
step number one is pick a goal that
you're having a hard time with pick a
goal that you're having a hard time
going up and doing not something easy
nothing that's automatic not something
that you're doing every day that you
could just check the box off and say
yeah i did it when you do the easy
things you don't feel great about
yourself it's good it's a little time
you win but it's the difficult things
what's one goal that you're having a
hard time right now accomplishing step
number two ask how can you make yourself
proud
what can you do today
to make progress on that goal in a way
that makes you proud and that's
different for everybody what makes me
proud might be different than you but
something that you could take an action
that you can do that would make you
proud of your effort i gave the same
challenge to alex who's also on a diet
alex helps me run toronto then salsa and
his advice is big macs so i told him
go to mcdonald's order a big mac order
it he loves a big mac sauce
open up the case smell it
[Music]
just smell that extra big mac sauce ask
for the extra big mass sauce so they
have to make it fresh for you right take
it smell it and then go outside and give
it to a homeless person because he loves
acts of service
you smell it
you give it to a homeless person outside
and then you pat yourself on the back
that's what would make him proud take
your goal the one you've been having a
hard time on stop trying to take the
easy way out on it and do something that
makes you proud of your effort that when
you come out of it that difficult thing
you're gonna say holy cow i'm awesome i
can't believe i was capable of that and
you get up tomorrow you do it again you
do it again you do it again step number
three is share it and celebrate you just
did something amazing
you just did something that you are
proud of share it and celebrate it
whether you want to post it to an
instagram story like mark did whether
you want to just go tell your friends
whether you want to post it on facebook
tell your best friend tell your parents
celebrate it yourself just celebrate put
on music dance celebrate
you need to celebrate the things that
make you feel proud because when you
celebrate it when you tell people about
it when you keep doing it it'll motivate
you to keep on going that momentum
becomes important that celebration that
sharing becomes important and i don't
think as entrepreneurs we often
celebrate enough about the effort we may
celebrate the results hey i crossed a
million views hey i got ex-subscribers
hey i won this award
but what you should be celebrating is
the effort of the work you're putting in
when it's hard so number one pick a goal
you're having a hard time with two find
a way to make yourself proud on it today
and then three celebrate and share it
the first thing is to understand the
conscious is reliant upon our cellular
memory
and the cellular memory is really stupid
it's a short-term memory so it needs
repetition
so if you think you know running a
marathon
on saturdays is going to affect your
life if that's all you do you're much
better running two miles a day than
running a marathon on saturday i promise
you because of the way the cellular
memory works it's taking the input every
day and it needs to be reminded the next
day and the next day in order for it to
communicate with your subconscious so 10
000 new data inputs or thoughts a day
they're determined upon our stupid
senses your eyes your ears your nose
your mouth and your touch they are not
accurate and then it relies on your
memory that's not accurate so through
the repetition you start getting stable
data that stable data goes to the
subconscious which now has about 40 000
of these intermediary thoughts and the
more you access them the more impact it
has on two things one the neural
pathways that are formed so those are
habits or disciplines or efficiencies i
like to call habits and disciplines
efficiencies and then that's also
determined on what you call on a memory
the unconscious competency
and why i say it's important is you have
to look at these four generations back
to your great grandparents grandparents
and parents because some people that
don't understand this consistent
behavior would say oh you know i smoke
how come i can't quit smoking after 21
days why do i still feel like i want it
and then other people can quit smoking
in one day
it's because genetically you're
programmed right that's why alcoholics
have alcoholic children's more uh
percentage-wise than not so if you know
your genetics you know that it's going
to take you longer or less time more
focus or less focus in order to
effectuate the continuum why the
continuum so important those if you keep
accessing the right subconscious
thoughts you actually can change your
dna there's an epigenetic layer of the
dna that activates these quantum
memories that you have these really
really long-term memories now scientists
can show that it's four generations i
believe it's like lifetimes
right right right yeah yeah i really
believe that so
for me i look at my personality traits
and how they change my characteristics
how they change my obsessions and
addictions how they change and that
creates a frequency and that frequency
is your vibration that's what makes
people different many years ago when i
was on the ellen degeneres show i was in
the green room with minnie driver and
minnie driver is a hollywood celebrity
who everybody knows around the world if
you watch a little bit of television and
i asked minnie a question
i asked her how is it that you can take
a script that your agent gives you and
how do you become
the role so that you can either win an
academy award or an oscar or any of the
awards that they give actors and
actresses and she said to me she said
john nobody's really ever asked me that
question and so let me share with you
what she told me that i think will help
you understand what it's going to take
for you to not just set goals but for
you to achieve your goals
she said to me that once she gets the
script she reads it three four five
times to see if it's really what she
wants to trade her life for
then she says when she accepts the
script and the contract that her agent
obviously connects her with the studios
with
she then goes
by a process of practice drill and
rehearse and what does that mean
well what it means is she takes hours
every single day to practice her role in
the script she does research on the role
and then once she thinks then feels that
she has the role really well felt in her
emotional self
she then moves that to the camera
now why does that process work well the
reason the process works is because when
we have a goal that we look at once or
twice or three times
our brains really forget what the goals
are unless we get it to go from the
conscious aware part of our personality
and our psyche and into the unconscious
implicit part of our brain and psyche
through rehearsal through practiced
repetition through practice drilling and
rehearsing every single day
what you do is you set up a new neural
pathway in your brain a new pattern for
your brain to not only emotionalize but
a new pattern for your brain to have you
think about a new pattern for your brain
to have you look for a new pattern for
your brain to get your physical body to
move into action towards
and so if you want to achieve your goals
and dreams
write out your script and then every
single day what i want you to do is read
the script
visualize and see yourself already being
in the role having achieved what you
want to achieve instead of just having
the goal
written on a piece of paper
what i want you to also do is i want you
to practice being that role
if your role is about being healthier
then i want you to visualize it i want
you to read it i want you to look at
whatever you've written or whatever you
have cut out in a magazine or from any
other source to be able to create a
collage
of that goal or that dream that you have
for yourself and then every day i want
you to take action towards that and
practice that role until
you and the goal and the dream become
one you have to go from the i want
part
to the i am part and the more you can
bridge the gap between what you want and
who you are the more you'll be able to
create an academy award-winning
performance in your own life the more
you integrate your vision with your
emotions
with your actions the more you will
become the role the more you will become
the person who sets goals and achieves
goals here's the reality check that hit
me like a ton of bricks
all of the joy and excitement and fun
that we want in life never comes from
external circumstances it always comes
from the energy and the attention and
the consciousness that we bring into
each and every moment so lori i talked
about this a lot and if you really want
to solve this problem i need you to go
read page 10 in my book make every man
want you it's all about making isness
your
business so what does that mean making
isness your business means that you show
up in each moment and you do this moment
like you friggin mean it that means you
bring your a game that means you bring
your full enthusiasm your attention your
love to whatever you're doing wherever
you are and whoever you're with why
because all pain and frustration and
annoyance in our life comes from
resisting the moment it comes from
saying this moment isn't how it should
be but guess what the moment already is
so you only have two choices in life you
can either resist it and be freaking
miserable or you can engage with the
moment and have a damn good time
in fact make it an engagement party you
guys
i'm engaged
[Applause]
with the moment
that's right you gotta love the moment
put a ring on it
because the truth is you can feel fully
alive in any situation or you can feel
like total crap in any situation it's
not the circumstances it's actually what
you bring to them once i really got this
i was so much happier i was performing
in my jobs better and ironically
everything that i wanted to create in my
future started happening a lot faster
habits
good habits will give you results that
stick
bad habits will destroy everything i
have some bad habits
that's right all my habits are not great
so if you've got some bad habits
don't feel bad so does your next door
neighbor so does your mentor your coach
so does your mother and father if
they're alive so does everyone and the
trick of life is to replace a bad habit
with a good habit
i used to hang around bars all the time
and one day i went in i picked up a
glass and i looked around and i thought
they're all bums in here
and then it dawned on me i'm always here
i learned something i put the glass down
i said i'm never coming back here again
and i'm never going to drink this and i
never did that was a long time ago but
you know what i did
i went from spending all my money on the
bar to race track and i started to bet
it all on horses so i went from making
somebody with a bar get wealthy and then
i started to feed the horses
and one day i woke up and i learned
something if you don't consciously and
deliberately replace a bad habit with a
good habit you will automatically create
another bad habit
now what is a habit a habit is an idea
that has been planted in the garden of
your subconscious mind
and then repetitively fed for a
sufficient period of time that you act
on it without giving any thought to it
i'll give you an example i want you to
right now mentally imagine you're
pulling on your underwear in the morning
what foot do you put in first
i put my right foot in if i tried to put
my left foot in my underwear first i'd
stagger and i'd fall over
you may say what's this got to do with
it it's got everything to do with it
why do i put my right foot you may put
your left certainly a lot of people do
well when i was just a little gaffer
didn't have a clue of how to put
underwear on my mother or my grandmother
or my father or somebody came along and
they had the underwear red put your foot
in here you rather
what did they do
they had the underwear prepared as if
they were going to put it on
and so pretty soon
i was doing it like they were doing it
they through repetition planted the idea
in my hand in my mind well now think of
this
you don't just form habits of how to get
dressed you form habits to do everything
that you do and some of them are not
that productive
any idea
that you keep dwelling on and impressing
upon your subconscious mind becomes
fixed in the subconscious mind a habit
is nothing but an idea that's fixed in
the subconscious mind that you act on
without giving any conscious thought
many years ago i went in to train the
prudential insurance company of america
their agents i ended up training all of
their agents
and i only got them to do two things
this is in the early 70s i got them to
form the habit of being in front of a
prospect before 9 a.m and ask everybody
they talked to to purchase 100 000 worth
of insurance i said you don't have to
sell them just give them the opportunity
to say no
you know the sales in that company went
up by hundreds of millions of dollars i
had a revive a retired vp tell me he
thought it was a billion
just changing two habits
what habit you want to change
i'm forever checking out habits i've got
i'm in the habit right now of changing
my diet
and you know something
i've been doing it for going on three
weeks it's getting easier but it's still
not that easy i still like to reach over
and eat some of that when nobody's
looking
doesn't work doesn't work i'm looking
what habit are you going to form and you
shouldn't try and form more than two at
once it'll become too big and too heavy
and you won't form any
make up your mind you're going to do it
every day every day every day
until
you don't have to think about it and
then you'll automatically do it i
guarantee you
this idea will change your life think
about it all day
because that is definitely an idea that
will give you results that will stick
[Music]
if you want to know the 10 small habits
that can have a huge return on your life
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there please
don't stay quiet because you know it
doesn't matter and you know it won't
play well in the room do not act like
you know
when you don't know